- This is dedicated to all the people
who are visionary enough to recognize the
enormous opportunities we've been given,
in this new digital age,
and who are brave enough
to demand and seek out happiness,
not only in their life
but also in their work.
What's up Vlog?
I'm about to go into the studio.
Actually, I'm in the studio.
About to record the
audiobook for Crushing It.
Pretty excited.
Baban was out 'til 4
o'clock in the morning.
The Super Bowl, so
I'm gonna kick him out,
'cause he's not allowed in here, but
here we go.
It took all those years for it to happen.
But now I feel like I'm finally at a place
where I wanted to be.
It's crazy that this is where it is.
But I love it.
If you don't care enough to induce others
to rave about you,
all you're doing is holding a spot for
someone who really does care.
The one who will waltz
in and displace you.
This book features
entrepreneurs at all levels
of financial success.
And all stages of influence.
But those currently at
the pinnacle of both,
share three characteristics.
A commitment to service,
a desire to provide value,
a love of teaching.
If your nature is that at
least 51 percent altruistic,
and only 49 percent selfish,
you have a real shot of breaking out
because the vast majority of people
are 70 to 99 percent selfish.
Right?
And it's very simple.
Global and local dynamics
with digital aren't working,
there's nuances,
and everybody thinks
that they're solving it
by having all these offices
which creates even more
cooks in the kitchens,
not less.
By doing one, centric,
strategic based partner
who also over indexes in
these three pillars of
being peacemakers, being
deep practitioners,
having willingness to allocate
heavy hours to engagement
and speed of production and cost,
now you got something.
So just finished up the
audiobook here in Minnesota,
and
which was fun, maybe
a weird kind of thing,
and now we're here at the Mall of America
and about to go to Radio Row
where the media is, with
some of our athletes.
And obviously people want
to know what I'm up to
with VaynerSports.
Let's go.
- [Host] Back here on
Live from Radio Row,
final day of broadcasting, we are here
in Minneapolis at the Mall of America,
and quite a surprise this is,
the great Gary V will
now sit down with us.
Gary, what's up, my man?
- Life is good.
Other than the fact that
I've seen way too many
Patriot jerseys.
- Sickening.
- Am I allowed to curse on this show?
- Absolutely.
- I fuckin' hate the Patriots.
So I'm struggling with that,
but other than that,
life is tremendous.
- [Host 2] Gary, so
much of your videos are
a great way to inspire
so many young people,
such as ourselves, promoting
themselves on social media.
We have a lot of young viewers right now,
obviously we're two young
broadcasters ourselves.
What would be the number
one piece of advice
you would give to people
who graduated from college
over the last year?
- Reverse engineer the
attention that comes
native to you, aka
there is so much more
attention on Facebook,
podcasts, YouTube, Instagram, Snap
than people realize,
and the fact of the matter
if I decided to be the
biggest sports announcer
over
tomorrow, I really think in four years,
I'm in the conversation.
And it's because I have passion for it,
I have knowledge for it,
but most importantly,
I understand distribution of it.
So everybody who's listening,
if you want to do something,
if you want to be the
guy that knows more about
the Lions than anybody on Earth,
or if you want to be
the person that is the
foremost experts on middle relievers,
you can actually do that.
And I'm stunned by
people not understanding
how much of a player
Bleacher Report and Barstool is,
in just seven to 10 years,
based on this thesis.
All of you fuckers understand this,
you either are not
willing to put in the work
to get there,
or two, you actually don't realize that
you're sitting on
disproportionate knowledge.
Thanks guys.
Real pleasure.
Yeah man, we're off to a good start.
18 months in, we're
getting some real players.
It is the core of my existence.
Matt was part of the company
when we bought a small firm
to get into the business,
so our relationship,
and Robert it's all very special but
from day zero for me,
Matt's been a part of that family
and I think
it is very interesting for me
to actually care about a Broncos game now
because you care about the person.
You have a lot of thoughts
about business and
all the things that are gonna be happening
off the field that we can control as
agents and agencies
much more than what can
happen on the field.
We think that there's a
huge arbitrage to be had.
There's a lot being left on the field
and after a bunch of homework,
both on who they were and what
they thought they could do,
came to the top of the list and
the conversation started.
The punchline is, outside of a couple of
sporting goods companies,
and a couple of
besides football cards and sneakers,
these kids are not making
real economics off the field.
Meanwhile, in my other life,
I'm representing 15 year old teenagers
on Musically, making $700
thousand dollars a year
in marketing.
And so, they can build
much bigger audiences,
and so it's getting to know them,
not making them become
Gary V and doing like me
and vlog all day and do all this
and be crazy.
No.
Who are you?
And where can you go?
So it's reverse engineering.
- Thank you for coming by.
- Thanks for having me.
- Great to meet you.
- [Gary] If you've been making excuses,
you'll be exposed.
At which point, you can decide to stop
dicking around and achieve
what you set out to achieve.
Or, admit that your version of Crushing It
looks a little different
than you originally thought.
- We gotta get a picture, man.
- I cannot
I know this guy!
I played so many darts with this guy!
- Oh my goodness, how have you been?
- It is so good to see you, man?
- What are you doing?
- [Gary] I love you brother.
- Have to get a picture with you.
- How are you?
- Awesome.
Awesome.
- Give a picture.
- This is a real college friend of mine.
Thank you, man.
I'll see you tonight.
- Yeah yeah.
- Text me, okay?
- Chase's dad.
- Hey, man!
Hey, man how are you?
- Good, good I know
Chase was runnin' around.
- I know I was trying
this is my brother, A.J.
- Hey nice to meet you.
- Tyler
- Nice to meet you.
- And Baban
- Hey great to meet you guys.
- It's a pleasure, man,
I'm glad we got to see you.
- My wife saw you
- [Gary] See, this book
is for two audiences.
The first is for people
who know to the depths of
their souls,
that they are born to
build something great.
Natural born entrepreneurs should find
all the information they need to
improve the current efforts
or start making plans
of their own.
Not just the young, not
just the tech oriented,
not just professionals
in established careers,
or those looking to renew themselves
because they've outgrown their industries.
Or worse, their industry is shrinking.
(reflective hip hop/pop music)